خلال زلزال هنشيل الذي ضرب اليابان عام
1995 قتل نحو سته الاف شخص الا مبنى واحد
في المدينه لم يتاثر بالزلزال العنيف
المبنى تملكه شركه انشاءات هندسيه يابانيه
جعلت اساساته من المطاط الخاص في نسخه
تجريبيه وقتها لتقنيه بناء تسمى تقنيه عزل
الالقاب اليوم بحسب نيويورك تايمز تستخدم
هذه التقنيه في نحو 9000 مبنى في اليابان
بينما زودت الاف المباني الاخرى باجهزه
امتصاص الصدمات فيما يقول خبراء ان عدم
اعتماد هذه التقنيات ضيعه فرصه حمايه
الارواح وتوفير مليارات الدولارات من
تكاليف اعاده الاعمال على كل حال هذا ما
يتضح في اعلان السلطات التركيه انها تخطط
لهدم اكثر من 50 الف مبنى تضرر بفعل
الزلزال الاخير كونها لا يمكن ترميمها او
حتى اصلاحها المزيد حول مواصفات المباني
المضاده للزلازل وتقنيات حول العالم
بخصوصها مع الزميل على سرحان
حتى يتسنى للمبنى الصمود في وجه القوه
الهائله الناجمه عن الزلازل يتعين عليهم
امتصاصه اكبر قدر ممكن من الطاقه التي
تولدها الهزه اليابان ودول مثل تشيلي
والصين وايطاليا والمكسيك وبيرو وتركيا
معرضه للزلازل فتبنى التقنيات بدرجات
متفاوته ومنها تقنيه الاساسات المعزوله
ومن المباني الشهيره التي تستخدمها مبنى
الكابيتول في ولايه يوتا حيث صمم لتحمل ما
يصل الى زلزال بقوه 7.3 درجه على مقياس
ريختر ايضا تقنيه المثبط الكتلي تعتمد على
كتله ثقيله متارجحه تعمل كبندول مركزي
مصمم للتارجح عكس الانحناءات مثل مبنى
تايباي 101 في تايوان بالاضافه الى مبنى
برج خليفه في الامارات كذلك تقنيه الجسر
المركزي لامتصاص الصدمات بين مبنيين عاليي
الطول عاده
مثل برج بتروناس التوام في ماليزيا في
الولايات المتحده تم تصميمه معظم المباني
لتنهار بشكل محسوب والهدف هو الحفاظ على
الارواح هناك البيوت بالخيزران او
بالبامبو في اندونيسيا وامريكا الجنوبيه
لما يتمتع به من قوه شد يتم تدعيمه
بالاسمنت بعد ذلك او الطين
[موسيقى]
بقسم الهندسه المدنيه بكليه الهندسه جامعه
الشارقه تخصص الهندسه الانشائيه
والزلزاليه دكتور يسعد صباحك منورنا في
الاستوديو اهلا بك اهلا وسهلا شكرا على
الاستضافه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم ابتداء
نترحم على من فقدت ارواحهم والذين هم تحت
الانقاض نسال الله لهم التيسير
والمهجرين ونسال الله عودا امنا لهم طيب
دكتور ارخبيل اليابان مثلا يقع على حزام
النار اكثر منطقه نشطه زلزاليه حول العالم
رغم ذلك عند وقوع اقوى الزلازل نشاهد
المباني الشاهقه تتمايل واكثر مرونه
وصمودا في وجه الزلزال مسر هذه المباني في
ذلك ان اليابان تصمم مبانيها على زلزال
كانتو الذي حصل عام 1923 وهم يستخدمون
البنايات المرنه ويستخدمون مبدا العزل
الزلزالي للاساسات فعندما يكون العزل
الزلزالي للاساسات ممكن تخفيف مقدار
الطاقه الناتجه من الزلزال الى المبنى
بمقدار 80%
عامل مهم من تخفيف التعجيل الارضي القادم
الى المبنى ومن ثم تصميم المباني بحد
ذاتها لكي تكون مرنه دكتور
هل منطقتنا هل الدول كل الدول العالم لها
القدرات لبنائها كذا مباني هذا الموضوع
طبعا يصمم في المباني الزلزاليه الواقعه
على الخط الزلزالي شديده التاثر وعاده في
في اليابان وفي كاليفورنيا في غرب امريكا
وفي غرب كندا لان قوه الزلازل تكون عاليه
وهذه كذلك مكلفه تقريبا هي 20% من من
تكلفه المبنى ولكنها عمليه بسيطه هي عباره
عن اجزاء يا اما من المطاط او الحديد
والرصاص يبلغ ارتفاعها بين 30 الى 50 سم
وتؤدي الى امتصاص الطاقه وبالتالي تخفيف
شده الهزه الارضيه الواقعه على المبنى
الدكتور زيد اليوم كثير من دول شرق
المتوسط تخشى من هزات ارتداديه سيكون وقعه
يوازي حجم وقع زلزال الذي حصل قبل اسبوعين
هل يمكن وطبعا فيها بيوت كثيره قديمه
وبنايات شاهقه هل يمكن لبيت قديم ان ندعمه
نرممه اليوم بطريقه يمكن ان تقاوم الزلازل
في المستقبل
الحقيقه الذي حصل في تركيا هو درس
للباحثين وللاكادميين ولاصحاب الاختصاص ان
الذي حدث يتوجب على الجميع كشراكه
اجتماعيه وكمؤسسات رقابيه ان تنظر الى
المباني التي القائمه وخاصه في هذه
المناطق اولا من ناحيه هل هي مؤهله
لشده الزلازل القادمه لاننا نعرف ان
المطلبات الزلزاليه تتطور مع الزمن اضربه
بذلك مثالا المدونه الزلزاليه الكنديه
تضاعفت ثلاث مرات من 1965 الى 2020 اي يجب
قدره المباني تتحمل ثلاث مرات اضعاف ما
تحملت سابقا فلذلك يجب ان يتم احصاء لهذه
المباني
معرفه مدى تحملها واذا كانت لا تواكب
المطلبات التصميميه للمتطلبات الحاليه يجب
ان يكون لها ترميم بحيث يعني
يستطيع ان تقاوم الزلازل هذه من ناحيه
المباني سموها سكينج وكذلك بالنسبه
المباني العاليه الشاهقه هنالك
اي نراقب هذه المباني على مدار الساعه من
خلال وجود مجات على طوابق المبنى تحسب لنا
قيمه التعجيل الارضي والازاحات على المبنى
وهي مرتبطه باجهزه الحاسوب بحيث نعرف تصرف
هذه المباني على مدارس ساعه لتكون لنا
يعني خبره ومعرفه لما سيحصل مستقبلا شكرا
جزيلا حدثنا في الاستوديو دكتور زيد سعدون
الاستاذ المساعد بقسم الهندسه المدنيه
بكليه الهندسه جامعه الشارقه شكرا جزيلا